[Music]
do you try to get every achievement in
the games you play well now you'll have
a better idea of how many players have
gotten each achievement thanks to a new
update from microsoft I'm Matt this is a
game spot news update and make sure to
LIKE and subscribe to keep up on
everything Xbox the latest feature added
to Xbox one tells you a percentage of
people who have unlocked any given
achievement down to two decimal points
previously there was a rarity level for
achievements but it didn't actually give
you anything specific it just let you
know that you've done something few
others had this new version of the
feature was revealed by xbox engineering
boss Mike ibarra who tweeted two images
of how it works with forza horizon 3 you
can check it out for yourself right now
in other xbox news Microsoft has
revealed that its e3 briefing will move
from its usual Monday morning slot to
Sunday afternoon this year we're
expecting to hear more about project
Scorpio which is due out this holiday in
addition to games like crackdown 3 and
state of decay too we'll keep you up to
date on all of the Xbox news but if
you're looking for something to play on
your xbox one right now there's an open
beta going for Ghost Recon wildlands and
we've got a video telling you the 5
things you should know before checking
it out